[Musique]
je suis fawzia zouari
je suis d'abord romancière je suis
écrivaine avant d'être militante mais je
parle pas à travers et par la voix d'une
femme et je ne peux pas faire autrement
et j'estime qu'il ya une écriture
féminine il ya un regard féminin sur le
monde le sait que depuis quelques années
depuis que les femmes écrivent il ya un
regard sur les saveurs du monde ya une
façon de le dire qui est à nous et il ya
de plus en plus maintenant une façon de
s'impliquer dans les problématiques par
exemple longtemps dans nos sociétés
arabo-musulmanes écrire pour une femme
était quelque chose qu'ils ne pouvaient
pas se concevoir
parce que c'est une façon de mettre
l'intime en évidence
et comme les femmes représentent
l'intime par essence pour les sociétés
musulmanes fallait surtout pas qu'elle
écrit
[Musique]
comment dire son point de vue sur le
monde sur des sujets d'actualité vous
avez eu le harcèlement il ya pas très
longtemps sur le corps des femmes dont
on parle sur l'écologie sur les guerres
pourquoi n'entend pas à parler la voix
des femmes sur les guerres alors
qu'elles en sont les victimes
moi je rêve de voir des grèves de mère
de femme dans des pays comme la syrie et
d'autres produits pour dire stop stop à
la guerre donc nous en tant que
romancière je pense que on va essayer de
dire c'est notre voie qu'il va falloir
entendre c'est notre voie qui va falloir
imposer dans des organismes officiels
qui font la paix et la guerre dans le
monde sans nous consulter
et surtout créer une solidarité entre
les écrivaines pour faire des choses
avec les femmes pour faire entendre la
voix de femmes pour faire en sorte qu'on
puisse dire
les romancières ça sert à quelque chose
les écrivaines les écrivaines d'une voix
les écrivaines s'engage
il y a une langue française que je veux
rebaptisé mais aussi redéfinir en la
débarrassant de toutes ses scories
masculine de toute une terminologie de
guerre que les hommes ont mis dans cette
langue en disant c'est notre tribu de
guerre c'est la langue du colonisateur
moi je dis non c'est ma langue donc
cette réappropriation de la langue
française m'intéresse de même que le
fait d'en faire une langue de solidarité
pas seulement contre les femmes mais de
solidarité envers l'autre on aimerait
être solidaire à travers une langue pour
promouvoir des valeurs universelles
[Musique]